[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here one of the
best ways to stay on track with a
fitness goal is to male prep whether
your goal is to loose weight put on
weight perhaps you are preparing for a
competition or you just want to stay fit
your daily males contribute 80% to your
success so what you eat matters what
exactly is meal prepping it is basically
preparing and planning your meals in
advance for the entire week so basically
making your own healthy and delicious
pre-packed meals instead of buying them
or eating out some of the benefits
include keeping you on track with your
fitness goal so you have no excuses not
to eat healthy secondly it eliminates
the stress of having to cook for every
single meal especially if you are a busy
mom work in person or busy student but
you get to save money and time not only
will you be saving money by not eating
out
you will also be saving on your gas and
electricity bills
by cooking in box and finally you get to
eat your own healthy and delicious meals
throughout the week so let's go through
the five easy steps to meal prep first
check your schedule and decide how many
days and how many meals do you want to
prep in advance for me I will go with
500 days and I will prep all my meals in
advance perhaps you might only want to
prep your lunch and snacks in advance
and have freshly cooked dinners well it
is entirely up to you and your schedule
the second step decide what you want to
eat be specific and write your meal plan
are you having three larger meals or are
you having five to six smaller meals for
this I will be using my eight-week
bikini body challenge meal plan which is
also available on my website so once you
know exactly what you will be having for
the entire week
go out there and get all the ingredients
you need and also get enough food
containers to store your meals try to
get them in similar shape and sizes so
that it will be easier for you to stack
them up in the fridge or freezer and
make sure that they are freezer and
microwave friendly once you have all
your ingredients ready the next
important step is to weigh and measure
your food this is especially important
if you are new to eating clean and you
are unsure about portion sizes where
your food will allow you to visually see
how large a portion should be and you
will know how many calories is in your
meal so what you need is a food scale
and also measuring cups and spoons I
prefer to weigh my ingredients prior to
cooking because depending on how I cook
how much water I use it may be different
from your meal after cooking and the
final step is to cook and have fun keep
it simple
remember that meal prepping should be
time efficient stress-free fun and easy
so pick easy and delicious recipes to
prep let's cook so here's my meal plan
breakfast
dreamy oatmeal snack peanut butter
energy bar lunch tomorrow rice and beans
snack banana muffins dinner baked salmon
with sweet potato and carrots and also a
side of creamy green soup and I'll be
prepping all this in 2 hours and 30
minutes let's start by making meals that
takes of the longest to cook
I'll start by cooking my rice an easy
tip to cook brown rice is to soak them
at least 4 hours or overnight so that
they will be soft and cook quicker next
peel and chop all the vegetables where
them if you need to this is the most
time-consuming process for me as I'm
rather slow at chopping it'll take me at
least 30 minutes to get this done place
all the vegetables in separate bowls for
easy cooking we want to be doing at
least two things together to save time
so start by preheating the oven first on
the list is to prep my dinner baked
salmon with sweet potatoes and carrots
as they will take 45 minutes to cook in
the oven
salmon is my protein and healthy fat
carrots my vegetable and sweet potato my
complex carbs once it's ready cook this
in the oven for 45 minutes when that's
cooking next is to make the banana
muffins as they will need to cook in the
oven as well combine all the mixtures
together separate them into chopped
muffin cups and once they're ready there
should be about 50 minutes cooking time
left on the oven place this on the top
part of the oven so right now I'm having
two Mills cooking at the same time in
the oven next on the list to cook the
creamy green soup and also tomato rice
with beans cut two parts with olive oil
one to make the creamy green soup and
another for the tomato rice and beans
while those ingredients are cooking in
the pots by now my salmon and banana
muffins will be done take them out of
the oven and allow them to cool down
okay
back onto the stove the beans and
vegetables should be done by now because
my pot is tiny I will transfer the beans
and vegetables into my rice pot and
combine all the ingredients together
lunch is now ready and set it aside to
cool down by now my soup will be ready
for blending removed from heat and plan
all the ingredients until smooth and
creamy done again set it aside to cool
down so now that all the time consuming
meals are ready I'll move on to the
easier meals peanut butter snack bar and
dreamy oatmeal both requires less than
ten minutes to prep combined peanut
butter honey oats and seeds
once that's done press it down firmly
into a square container and place it in
the fridge to cool down and harden
before slicing finally let's make
breakfast
I only prep my breakfast two days in
advance as I do not like my oats to be
too soggy so two layers of oats with two
layers of fruits my dreamy oats are now
ready to go into the fridge overnight
time to pack my meals up for five days
this is the most satisfying part of the
process
so here are my healthy prepared meals
for five days this is an example of my
meals in a day aim to have a balance of
carbs protein vegetables fruits and
healthy fat in your meals as a general
guideline you can't keep your meals in
the fridge for up to two days and you
can freeze them up for up to one week to
warm your food up the easiest way is to
warm it up in a microwave if you do not
want to use a microwave then transfer it
into a bowl and steam it up so pick one
day in a week where you will have the
time to run your meal plan go out and do
your grocery shopping come back and cook
your meals it only took me two and a
half hours to prep my meals for the
entire week so try meal prepping out to
stay on track with a fitness goal don't
forget to snap a picture and share with
me on Instagram or Facebook for new
Fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
You Tube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
[Music]